after years of crippling international
sanctions Iran is about to get some
fiscal relief when the sanctions are
lifted Iran will have access to roughly
a hundred billion dollars in foreign
reserves that have been frozen but that
doesn't mean that the country has hit
the Powerball Iran will only have access
to about fifty billion dollars of that
pot why only half Iran has a lot of
bills twenty billion dollars is gonna go
to pay for projects underway in China
and tens of billions more are already
committed to loans to the country's
energy and banking industries and their
competing demands for the 50 billion
dollars that remain Iranian officials
have said they need 29 billion dollars
to rebuild the country's mining and
steel industries and another hundred
billion dollars to overhaul its energy
industry however without sanctions Iran
should be able to start making money
again by exporting the country has the
fourth largest crude oil and second
largest natural gas reserves in the
world its oil minister says right away
the country will pump 500,000 barrels a
day more and in six months it will boost
production by 1 million barrels for a
total of about 4 million barrels a day
these new exports should yield about 5
billion dollars a year depending on the
price of oil for the next eight years
Iran will not be open to most us-based
companies in fact most US sanctions
against Iran will remain in place there
are two exceptions foodstuffs and
carpets to start looking in stores for
Iranian pistachios and Iranian caviar